hey
I love you
my mind kept repeating a single thought
he had taken from me my innocence I used
my heart everything
foreign
really nobody's gonna crack open the
book they're in there why do they like
this so we don't steal them are you for
the engineering club I'd like to enter
this the fifth annual underwater
robotics competition so you want to go
up against the best tech schools in the
country it says they Scout for
internships and jobs
you guys got some ground to make up the
other teams will have more money than
you so you're still short
432.50 and my man ate a couple ice
creams on the way in and I have an ice
cream too late
wrote the check okay we gotta find cheap
creative ways to build this thing how do
we fix it you gotta stop the sleep it's
small and really absorbent
[Applause]
next case city of Atlanta versus Mabel
Simmons hey Carmen hey bro if the Lord
get me out of this I'm going by the
church
you better mean it too
you better mean it
hey Chad oh girl your hair is so pretty
who doing your hair Lord have mercy how
you doing Mabel Simmons you come before
me more than you go to the doctor for a
challenge I'd change my life you ain't
got to say no I am living for the Lord I
am living for the Lord I am living for
the Lord hallelujah I feel him down in
my spirit you know as I think about the
goodness of Jesus and all that he has
done for me my soul Cries Out hallelujah
thank God for
you finish
hello everyone and welcome to the
Academy's visiting artists film series
film Aid Edition for film editing I'm
Dodie darn here in Los Angeles I'm a
governor of the academy in the editors
branch
I have the distinct pleasure of
introducing Maisie Hoy who I've known
for over 40 years
a long time
and I'm very proud and humbled to be
able to introduce her to you the amazing
Maisie hoy
uh thank you Dodie I mean people don't
know that Dodie herself is a a
well-respected editor in her own right
so she's has a great body of work so get
onto the web and check out her resume
anyways
um hi to everyone
um my name is Maisie Hoy I'm a film
editor and I live in Los Angeles as well
and
um I guess where where do we start Dodie
from the beginning yeah first I just
want to thank you so much for doing this
uh it really means a lot to the students
I know uh and other people out there who
are who are watching this so it's really
great that you're willing to share your
time and your experiences and I would
just love to know how you first got
started in the film industry
well it
it's I started out as an actress you
know living in Vancouver and at a very
very young age this is very strange I
think as far back as I can remember when
I was like four or five years old this
is what I wanted to do which is crazy
because you know where I grew up with a
very traditional parents
um being Chinese and very very old
school
um that was the furthest thing from
their minds of what I should be doing
and so uh with that in the back of my
mind it just sort of I you know to
please my family
um I told them I I wanted to be a nurse
but when I graduated I said okay
um I don't know how I'm going to get
into the film business but I'll go and
study to be a dietitian and then in my
spare time I could find acting work and
so one day
I'm in the cafeteria of this college and
I see all these students having fun they
were just having a great time so I
approached them and I said
um can I ask you what classes you guys
are in or what's your major and go
Theater Arts I go oh wow that's great I
said I didn't even know they had a
theater arts program here and and I said
well how do I get in it and they said
well first of all you go to your
counselor and ask to be transferred I
said okay great so I head off to the
counselor's office and you've got to
understand that Vancouver is a very
provincial kind of city in fact very
stoic very English so
I walked into the counselor's office and
there's a woman sitting behind the desk
gray hair with Big Bun she was really
really nice and I said to her I said
look I want to transfer out of the
dietitian program and get into the
theater arts program and she kind of
looked at me and said
well are you sure this is what you want
I said yeah this is something I've
dreamed of doing all my life and she
goes you know there's not going to be a
lot of work for somebody like you and I
looked at her and I got
well it doesn't matter I said this is
what I want to do so can you please sign
my transfer
um uh sign the transfer for me to get to
the theater program so she signed it
and off I went to the basement of this
college and
um I walked in and there was this very
English looking gentleman who ran the
program and it was Tony Holland and um
he was
he had worked at the Bristol obit in
London and now he was living in
Vancouver and he was head of the theater
program so
I gave him the transfer note and he
looked at the transfer note he looked up
at me a couple times and he goes why do
you want to do this and I go well I want
to be an actress and he said this
basically the same thing he goes you
know there's not a lot of work for
somebody like you I looked at him I go
just let me in the class you don't even
have to talk to me you don't have to
bother me let just let me in the class
and so you know so he did and it's
interesting because many years later you
know I became good friends with his wife
and the wife her name was gusta and she
said to me she says you know he came
home that day and he said can you
believe it there's this Chinese woman
that wants to be an actress and besides
she's not that pretty and I and so
anyways I always use this against him
because when I'd see him after I
graduated and came to uh Hollywood and
made a career myself he would always
look at me sheepishly and said and say I
really really sorry about what I said to
you I said you know what what that did
was it's motivated me to create my own
program or find my own way so once again
I'm sitting you know in my friend's
office apartment and
she said you know they're casting this
movie in town I go what what as well
it's Robert Altman he's doing a movie
called McCabe Mrs Miller and so
she said you know what you should see if
you can get on that
and so then at the time
I met somebody who at that time had a
book
of actors and I got involved in that you
know they take your picture they put it
in this book and they give it to the
casting directors and so one day I get
this phone call from somebody called
Graham Clifford now Graham now is a
director but he was a casting director
so he brought me in and we sat and we
talked a lot and so then I sort of like
left it and he goes well you know Bob is
going to be in town in about a month so
I I'm I'm going to keep you in mind so
just stay in touch and so
I get a phone call from Robert Altman
's office and Graham said well you know
Bob wants to meet you and so I said okay
so I at that time I didn't have a car
but I took a bus Which took about an
hour to get to where Bob was and anyways
I walked in and I think he was sick
I mean he was laying around on a couch
and he looked up at me he goes I don't
stand for Horrors and I go
at that point I knew I got the job
because in the cave of Mrs Miller they
had the only women's part in that movie
were prostitutes
and so that's how I met Robert Altman
and so from that point on you know I was
in that movie and when I finished the
movie
um I couldn't get any work you know
um I think I got a job on a CBC film uh
a series and I played a receptionist and
so that was about it they weren't
casting Asian women and this is before
Vancouver became like The Place To Shoot
movies and
um television shows because when I left
they created an incentive so you know
the nickname for Vancouver is Hollywood
North
so after after
being unemployed for a while you know I
take odd jobs just so that you know pay
the rent and and things like that and so
I finally said to once again my friend
Joan in the basement of her apartment
um I said you know what I gotta get out
of here because if anybody has ever been
to Vancouver they call
Vancouver part of the Northwest
rainforest
so it rains 360 days out of 365 days and
I got I said I got to get out of here I
can't stand this rain anymore so she
says have you thought about writing to
Robert Altman and I go well that's an
idea so
I wrote to him
never heard back and then I read in the
trades that he was doing this picture
called California split right I had no
idea what it was
so
I just made a random phone call
you know to him in California and I
reintroduced myself to him and I said
you know what
um I'd like to come to California to Los
Angeles and just sort of Shadow you
because I want to be a director and he
said to me goes do you play poker and I
go well I I can learn sort of yeah I
kind of know how to play poker and he
goes okay be here January 13th
I swear to God within a week I was gone
and I tell people
the story because
my parents being immigrants had very
little English
um had understood very little English so
I said to my mother you know on the day
I was leaving I mean they sort of had an
idea I was up to something
um and so
um I left
I only knew two people
Robert Altman and a kid I went to church
with I knew he was going to Arts Center
and I knew I had a place to stay for a
week so I had my sleeping bag and my
backpack and I left
and I'll tell you the weirdest thing
that happened
was the minute I landed in Los Angeles
I knew this is where I belonged
that's great
and so you know you know your feet hit
the ground and it was like okay it just
this is where where you're supposed to
be
I love that I love that you know that
was just what I would call a master
class in moxie
yeah
because you just took uh these small
scraps or you know little strings of of
opportunities and turned them into into
your life and it's fantastic story I
love it and and I think it was
um to know that that's not what you do
you know call up a director you know
like that but
yeah you know it it was interesting
because when I got on the set
I looked around and I all these
different departments right and I kind
of made a plan in my head and I go okay
this is what I'm going to do I'm in a
situation where I could learn a lot you
know from these different people and so
I decided okay I'm going to create my
own Robert Altman Film School
so every day I would spend because they
would see me on the set you know the
crew would see me on the set and they
always wondered what who is this person
what is she doing here and so when I
explained to them
that I knew Bob and I was in his movie
and I got it was an interesting dynamic
because then they looked at me
in a different way they they were very
help everybody on the crew was very
helpful and I think that I was protected
by knowing him so nobody treated me
badly even though the guys were trying
to hit on me and that was like you know
um part of part part of the environment
and so I decided okay let's see today
I'm going to spend the day with the
sound people
and that was
um with Jimmy Webb and Chris McLaughlin
and at that time he was just creating
the eight-track sound
so I would sit with them and ask them
questions they they were very helpful
they didn't say you know beat it kid
um and then the next day I would spend
it with the electrical department where
I met my future husband I didn't know
this but and then the next day I would
hang out with the camera people and the
supervisor
and the Wardrobe people because you know
I I could sew and I met this lovely
wardrobe man his name was Huey and he
had been a wardrobe person for Fred
Astaire and Robert Wagner and he took a
liking to me he was an older gentleman
and he'd come to work in a three-piece
suit and a fedora and
so I think he must have been like 70 and
so he's whispered to me goes okay this
is what you got to do kid when they call
for wardrobe or they call Huey you go
here so you replace me so you run up and
you ask them what do you need and then
then they'll say oh go to Elliot's
trailer and grab what whatever and so
that's what you do so you run and you
get the clothes and you come back and
you give it to them and so I did that on
the set
and of course you know as things would
happen they went to
Reno Nevada to shoot some you know
um
um scenes for the casino
and
the script supervisor was pregnant
and
um I have to backtrack because when I
was on the set of California split there
was one day Alan Rudolph was the second
A.D assistant director came up to me and
he goes
do you know how to hold script I go y
goes well Carol's sick she you know it's
got morning sickness real bad she says
well do you know how to hold script I go
yeah
and that wasn't true because we had
video classes at the college and I knew
that you know you'd time the stop and
then that was about it so I go yeah so
give me the script and here I was I was
holding a script and I worked for like
two days as a script supervisor on this
movie
and so
anyways
at that time Bob looked at me like
second day or something you look at me
and goes you know you actually do that
pretty well oh thanks and and then from
that point on when we went to Reno
I also helped with the script
supervising
so from that point on I just sort of
kept hanging out you know at his office
because I had nowhere else to go you
know and these are really you know nice
people they were fun
can you give us a really brief
description of what a script supervisor
does because a lot of people they don't
put those two words together and have
any idea what it means script supervisor
well the script supervisor
um take notes she sits next to the camp
well now they're in video Village but
she's the closest person to the director
because she has to take care of the
continuity meaning from scene to scene
um if somebody's wearing a hat in one
scene and the next scene
they need to be wearing the Hat they
can't not be wearing the Hat because it
needs to be consistent she also
um takes care of the script in terms of
the timing
she writes down the lens that's used you
know in the filming
she makes notes whether it's a visual
effect that they're shooting or a plate
she also hands when she's done with the
day she gives the editors a log of what
was shot and the script pages of what
was shot that day and so that's my guide
to what I'd be seeing in terms of
dailies and dailies that's a word
we use for
scenes that was shot the day before
and so when I get the dailies the next
day
that's what it is is that clear enough
yeah Dodie it's great yeah because
um a lot of people don't understand that
the script supervisor is really the
connection for us especially these days
since we don't watch dailies together
anymore on film you're getting a lot of
information from the set to your editing
room through the script supervisor's
notes so a lot of times I develop a
relationship with a script supervisor
for that reason so that I can get the
information and and I just think it's
interesting also the script supervisor
makes sure that all the words in the
script are said at least in one take
right right
and also the sound report right and you
know the sound is very very important to
us maybe on the set most of they don't
care you know and so the script
supervisors also my goal between to talk
to the director and to the DP the
Director of Photography the
cinematographer because
you if something goes wrong on the set
or you have
um dailies that are confusing or the
camera move is kind of uh weird in terms
of it being shaky or what really bothers
me is when
um an operator is shooting a close-up on
an actor and he reframes in the middle
of a shot
and you go how am I going to use that
and so instead of going to the producer
which is a really bad No-No
um you go I'd go to the script
supervisor unless I've been on the set
when I was working with Tyler
I would go to the set
the first week of shooting
and part of it was to sit with him
because when he first started he was a
stage director and so I would sit with
him and I'd look at Framing and I you
know kind of talked to him a little bit
about the scene or I just sit and watch
and
I develop a relationship with the
cinematographer the sound people the
Wardrobe people the makeup people so if
if anything went wrong after I left I
could make a phone call to to the DP and
go hey you know what I just want to give
you a heads up here's what your camera
guy is doing I said can you tell them
not to do that so that he then knows
that I'm not threatening him or or
causing him problems you know with the
producer or even going to the director
because the director has a lot on their
minds and the last thing they want to
hear is okay camera guy is not doing his
job but on one occasion this happened
so when I was working with Tyler on
Daddy's Little Girls we had a lot of out
of focus shots and he called me up he
goes what is going on and I go well
you know I'll talk to the cameraman and
see what's going on with these guys and
they said well you know the operator
said the actor's moving too much in the
scene I go that's their job you know to
figure out focus if they're moving back
and forth I said that's a that's not a
great excuse so from that point on Tyler
would always ask me goes I want you to
tell me what's in focus and what is out
of focus well can I go back a little bit
and ask you about what the transition
was like going from acting to
post-production and what prompted it
it's not you've already you're kind of
in the middle of answering that but then
also how you're acting informed your
craft as as an editor anyway in general
well the transition from acting to
post-production and eventually to
editing happened when I was working with
Robert Altman
um
I became a PA on Nashville
and um I was PA to the Wardrobe
Department
and um from after we finished with
Nashville Bob decided that he wanted to
do Buffalo Bill and the Indians and it
happened that Buffalo Bill and the
Indians was a period piece it was set in
the 1880s and so they needed somebody to
do research
um on that time period you know for the
production design for the Wardrobe uh
for the dialogue and just sort of events
that were happening during the 1880s
and so he kind of looked at me and he
basically said okay you go do the
research and I you know once again you
know sitting in the room when it all
happened and so
um I started doing the research on
Buffalo Bill and the Indians and then I
went on location with them and was also
the PA to the Wardrobe Department
um and after we finished shooting when
we got back to Los Angeles
um
you know I knew the editors from all the
other movies that that Bob did and so
one day I'm walking down the hallway and
back in the day of film we had trim bins
we had where you put the film you put
put the film on hooks you'd mark it and
it all had to go back into roles so that
the editor when they put it up on the
chem or the steam deck
that everything was in sync and so there
must have been 20 you know of these bins
and I'm walking down the hall and I see
this two pair of legs you know
it was like a cartoon inside this bin
and you see all this film flying out
which was really another big No-No
because
you can't have any scratches on film and
as an assistant if you tear film then
you'd have to get a reprint which meant
it was more it would cost the company
more money
so I tap
this guy and I knew who it was and I go
what are you doing and he goes I'm
looking for two frames
now we're on electronic editing
equipment now two friends is nothing you
know but back in the day when you've got
20 bins of film and you got to look for
the two frames you need somebody to help
you so I looked at him I go well it
looks like you need help he goes yes we
need an apprentice we need somebody to
put this stuff together and I go well I
think I can do it he goes yeah you could
most definitely do it I said so he goes
well you had got to go ask Bob I go oh
God
okay so I walked across the the way and
at that time Robert Altman to me was
like seven feet tall in reality he was
probably six one okay I'm five feet one
and so walked in and he's pacing and I
was trying to test what mood he was in
and so anyways I'll go okay fine you
know what he's gonna say no so I walked
up opened the door and walked in and got
um
Bob you know um the editors need uh help
you know in reconstituting the film
and I says I I think I can do it you
know they need an apprentice and you
look down at me goes this isn't a film
school you know and I go uh uh well well
I know that but you know what they still
need help I kind of looked at me goes
okay if it's okay with the guys it's
okay with me and I go it's okay with the
guys and man I ran out of that place so
fast before he changed his mind so
that's how I got him to editing I became
an assistant
on Buffalo Bill because he shot like a
million feet of film so it had to be
organized they had three editors on the
show and so that's basically how I got
into editing and from that I got a huge
You Know lesson in post-production how a
film is shot
and in my background I've been so
fortunate you know growing up in this
business seeing
amazing dailies knowing where like
working with a director that knows
exactly where to put the camera so when
I'm working now
you just get this feeling it's ingrained
in my bones that I know when it's a good
shot or when it just like uh that just
doesn't feel you know feel right because
I I you know sat in the room when Bob
would come in and give notes to the
editors
and you know I'd sit there and I'd
listen to what he had to say and I would
kind of like you know look at the film
and kind of try to maybe you know second
guess what or guess what he was gonna
say and so that's how I I got into
post-production and the reason why I
decided that I I wanted to be in editing
was
you know because acting I didn't want to
um go out for the one line the one line
uh when I was 30 40 50 60 70 you know
and I said you know if I became an
editor
they couldn't judge me on the way I
looked they would judge me on my resume
you know my body of work and if they did
then well it's too bad for them you know
I don't particularly want to work with
you know people like that and so in
editing a film
I think that the acting helped me
because I would find
the the truth of the character I mean
you know when you're acting you've got
to find the motivation you got to figure
out their back story and so as an editor
I try to put myself in as a character
yeah that that's right all the little
moments you're always looking for but
that's a great lead-in to the this other
question of of how you find the best
moments in and out of a scene
well I think you sit and you watch you
know
um I guess with an actor's eye and an
editor's eye
um and um you just listen you know to
the performance and you watch the
behavior of the character and this is
where leaving the scene I know about
timing because that's where my improv
background comes in because when you're
on on the stage and you're just sort of
winging it and you have this feeling
like oh my God I I think I'm dying in
the scene then somebody comes in and
saves you and so having having
learned that and had having participated
in improvs you just get a feeling so I
think that as editors there's a lot of
times when you know a director will say
well why did you pick that take and I go
well because it felt right
right absolutely because basically
you're not going to say well I'm
discounting your feelings because that's
a whole other you know conversation but
but you you just feel the scene and for
any of the students wanting to get into
editing you have to trust your instincts
you know and that's the Great lead into
this question of of if a director is
especially attached to one shot or
sequence and you believe it kills the
momentum of the film at large how do you
have that conversation you were touching
on it right there trusting your
instincts
well you have a very gingerly
conversation because their egos are
about you know or about this big
um what I do is I propose it I'll say
well you know what I don't think we need
this shot or I feel it's slowing you
know the momentum and they go like no I
don't think so and you go okay you leave
it alone
I'm gonna work on the other scenes and
you come back and then you go you know
what I still feel that it's stopping you
know the movie and they'll kind of look
at me and I go okay I'm dropping it you
know I'm not going to revisit this until
the very end
and so as we're being brutal with
putting our movie In Shape that's the
way when we become ruthless and so real
this and why you're doing you're
servicing the film not ruthless because
the editor has an ego that I oh you know
okay uh two points for him and two for
me so now we're gonna draw and so I
bring it back up and I go you know I've
been watching it and like uh you know
the last three Cuts I said it it's
stopping the scene and and and stopping
the momentum of the movie and they'll
finally go
yeah yeah all right you know take it out
or if there is a scene
that is really in between two other
scenes right and you go you know why
don't we don't need this scene it's we
already know what what's gonna happen
we're it the dialogue is giving us you
know foreshadowing everything so you
don't we don't need it and they'll kind
of look at me and I go here's what you
do
put it in your next movie get the little
card and put it in your next movie and
so and I think I'd do it with humor
because you know our job is to
facilitate their vision
and and the ego is creating the best uh
film we can together and being a good
collaborator and then there there are
maybe once in a while there are editors
or no directors that are writers you
know so when you're interviewing when
I'm interviewing with the director who's
also a writer
and my question is are you going to be
holding on to things that you've written
oh no no no no no I'm I'm really good
with that and then when you get down to
just like no we really need that scene
and I'd look at them I go uh what do we
what did you tell me in that first
interview you know
um and so
it is sitting and watching you know the
movie a lot and that's when people ask
is well don't you get bored watching the
scene over and over and I go well no
because I'm looking at different things
I don't know about you Dodie but we're
always looking at the whole frame
you know it isn't just the performance
yeah absolutely and and what I'm hearing
is uh is this really intimate
relationship that you're developing with
your directors so you have those
conversations in the interview and then
you actually are bringing it back when
you're working together and I think
that's uh I think that's fantastic
um so I have a few more questions that
these come from some of the students in
Kenya uh if you have any uh any
interaction with the them on the color
grading with the director and the
finishing prod product and uh how that
works and if you want to say anything
about that and how it affects the
overall emotion of the film
well I think that you know our our job
we start we start our job when they
first start shooting
though I wish that we started sooner
um because I think we have a lot of
input into
you know scenes and and the overall look
or on the sound that's involved
um so I'll give you sort of a timeline
and that'll explain that question so i i
s we start editors start on the first
day of shooting
and then
um they finished shooting we present our
cut to the director the director looks
at it and then at that time we start
having discussions about the sound of a
scene the overall look of the movie
um and so once he's happy with his cut
and we're locking the picture
I stay on to supervise the color
correction uh the sound of the movie
We're on the mix the music we we talked
to the composer and
we're the keeper of how how it looks you
know when we speak for the director I
mean when I I'm in a situation when I'm
working with Tyler
um he leaves after his cut and I take
over and I do all all of the color
correction I'm on the stage
um listening to the sound making sure
it's what he wants and talking to the
composer
um of you know the music where where it
should be cued uh we have uh sessions
what we call spotting sessions meaning
the sound effects uh supervisor comes
into my room along with the visual
effects supervisor if you you know and
um the music supervisor and the composer
so we sit and we run through the movie
and we stop and go and and the composer
would say or I would say you know he
wants mute title Wants Music in here or
they just get a feel of it and we're
talking through this whole process and
and the the sound supervisor gets to see
the whole movie so he has an idea of
what it should sound like in certain
scenes
um and then we go off and we do our jobs
and um the composer invites me to listen
to the score
um and I tell people look you know what
I'm here representing Tyler and I hear
representing any of the directors I've
worked with I said so
if I ask you to do something
and you think it's it's not something
you want to do I said well you know
first of all you know let me know and we
talk about it but a bottom line is if it
gets screwed up then I'll take the
responsibility it's not I'm not going to
put it on you
um but you know we're here to do a job
together
um and so
which leads me in terms of the sound and
the color of the picture when we were
doing the Joy Luck Club
um if you examine that if you look at
that movie closely there are no
dissolves or fade outs in that entire
movie in that two hour and 15 minute
movie and the reason for that was
when I was talking to Wayne Wang the
director I said um how are we going to
deal with transitions I said you know
I'm not a fan of dissolves or fade outs
but if you you know if you want them
we're going to do it and he goes well
we're going to do an a B on it which
means
they do it in the lab you don't get to
see it you know before it goes to the
lab and I said to him I go well that's
scary I said I don't like that because I
don't I I I don't get to see how the
dissolve works because you sometimes you
put a dissolve in and you go oh my God
you know you got to start noodling with
it but because they do it in the lab
it's done you can't undo it unless you
go back and redo that thing so I said to
Wayne he and I decided Well
well how about this why don't we do
sound effects
so
in that movie
before women were different elements one
was water one was fire one was wood one
was wind and so especially the scene
um where Lindo
the woman that gets married off to this
young boy when she decides to get out of
this arranged marriage
um at the end when she
tells
her mother-in-law that
made is actually carrying her son's baby
and that's how she got out of that you
know out of that marriage and so the
line goes well Yun Tai Tai got her
grandson and I got a one-way ticket to
Shanghai and so in that scene when you
hear that narration the narration
Bridges us into
the in the into the past present
and on top of that you hear the sound of
a train crossing that scene and it
morphs into cable car
which is now we're in San Francisco
right that's great I love that I love
that so you're using audio as your
transition instead of visual and if it's
effective and it's doing doing all that
then it's it brings the audience in and
they or like I like to say the sound
sucks you into the next scene
right and we did it throughout the whole
movie you know and subliminal level and
um
um and it you know it worked you know
really well uh in in that movie and um
which brings me to you know I think
there was a question about are there
things that we create that are not in
the script you know to to help forward
the movie and and as seeing once again
in the jury Luck Club
where this the scene is with um
uh the same woman uh ying ying and her
daughter
um living in this crooked house and so
she's walking around and her whole thing
is you know I'm like a tiger on a prowl
um
so Wayne comes into my Cutting Room and
and he had this look on his face like oh
what's going on and he goes well I've
been accused of this and I guess I'm
I'll be accused of it again I go what is
that he goes being abstract I go well
let's talk about it I go what's on your
mind and he goes well
I'm having
I'm thinking I I'm not quite sure how we
bridge this
this scene where she's walking around
and it feels like it could be too long
and um I said well what do you think
about this you know you know because
editors and directors we we actually
spend a lot of time talking a lot of
people when they walk by The Cutting
Room they go oh they're just talking
they're not working but we get a lot of
work done just talking and and delving
into things and I said to him I go or
here's a woman that kills her baby you
know it's 20 years later I said she's
still gonna be thinking about that
almost daily I said what have we just
cut a bunch of stuff that that builds up
to that moment and then
um he had shot uh the vas breaking you
know and it kind of cues
um
the the one woman and her husband to
look up the noise cues them Something's
Happened upstairs and so that's how that
Montage came about that you see the baby
you see the the bad husband and the
watermelon and we accentuated all those
sounds you know and so at the end is
when the Voz breaks and once again it
echoes through the house and that cues
the daughter to come up and to get the
final lesson
that's that's great I love that and that
wasn't in the script at all so I I
really that was fun that was a fun one
to work on create that montage
that's true
with with the material you have and and
really going above and beyond and from
what you're describing obviously your
career has been so busy and jam-packed
how did you balance work and family and
and coming back to work after some time
off with your children how did you
balance all that and how did you manage
to come back
well I decided to take like a Hiatus
from working as
um a sound editor actually because when
I work with Bob I would like on three
women for instance
um he put me in that movie
um and and how I got that job was once
again I'm walking down the hall and he
looks at me and goes you're Doris and
you're going to Palm Springs I go okay I
don't know what that means
and
but the backstory to that there's always
a back story here is that I was living
with uh Scotty Bush now we were sharing
an apartment and one morning you know
the phone rings at like six o'clock in
the morning and
um she's on the phone for like at least
two hours you know I get up shower I'd
go sit down have coffee with her and she
goes well that was Bob I go oh really
what what did he want he goes well he
had a dream
we're doing a movie called three women
so that was the reference
which is crazy right love it
so so
that's when he pointed to me like okay
you're Doris who was one of the the spa
workers that turned out doors in one of
the spa workers and so
um I went to Palm Springs and I went to
Palm Springs not only as an actress but
an assistant film editor
so I was doing double duty here and
um when I was
finished acting I would help Dennis my
editor put the dailies together
and so
um
from that point on then I would work in
um
when we got back
I transitioned to working in sound
and so then I became a sound assistant
and so one day
I'm working on on the show and this this
great guy a great another Mentor
um Bill Stevenson said to me goes what
are you doing he goes you know you're a
sound assistant you're never going to
get a job being an editor you know I I
you know you need to go pursue that
and I kind of looked at him I go you
know what you're right and so I said you
know what I gotta take time off I said
uh I gotta regroup and figure this out
and so that figuring out
took eight years so I was on Hiatus I
didn't have a job you know I decided uh
you know I was having a family and um it
just turned into a an eight-year
hold
um my husband is also in the business
you know he was a gaffer and um so he
worked and I stayed at home taking care
of my two boys and but I did something I
guess it was intuitively you know and
this is the advice I give to men and
women who are deciding to start a family
I said you know every month I would call
up Bill Stevenson or I'd call up the
editors that I had worked with and I go
hey you guys want to go have coffee or
lunch and we'd spend a couple hours
having you know coffee and lunch and so
then my husband had a really bad year
um he had worked with this one cameraman
and they had a big falling out and so my
husband was out of work and I was out of
work for like a whole year
and so I said to him I go okay I gotta
get back I got to get back to work
because I'm a member of The editor's
Guild which is a union and I could I was
in good standing because I paid my dues
and so I called up Bill and I said hey
Bill Stevenson I said I'm looking for a
job
do you have a job and he said to me he
goes well I don't have to I don't have
anything for at least a month
he goes but I can't pay you much because
he was always cheap right and he goes I
could only pay you as an as an
apprentice I go I don't care you know at
that time I think an apprentice is
making like 700 a week which is better
than you know being answering phones and
so
that's what happened I worked with him
for like like when when the sh when his
show came in he he honored that promise
and I worked with him and then during
that time
um I was working
um I went to
um a wedding Raja gosnell's wedding who
used to be our Dennis and I had he was
our apprentice and assistant well now
he's a big time you know director and uh
he was getting married and so
um I saw Dennis at the reception and
where else would you meet an editor but
at a bar and so we stood there and
because hey I hear you getting back in
the business I'm going yeah I said why
you have a job for me uh we had a really
good relationship that we could bicker
like that right and I go why yeah you
know what you're looking for an
assistant he goes yeah as a matter of
fact I go oh really and he goes I go
what happened to your other assistant I
said did she find a better editor and so
he goes yeah she went on to greener
pastures anyways do you want a job I go
yeah yeah I need a job and so he hired
me to do Major League
so that's how I got back as an assistant
then I met
Danny Green because
after that show Dennis had another job
and so there was a post-production
supervisor Gloria Clark and she was
really nice and so that job fell through
but I helped her on another job I came
went over to her house uh and helped her
with the list I mean just doing my job
and so
what happened was she had a friend named
Danny Green who
um was a very well known you know editor
he cut Blazing Saddles mashed very well
established editor and she said oh I
have a friend who's looking for an
assistant I go really and she said yeah
can I give him your name I said sure and
he calls me and interviews me over the
phone and I get hired by Danny Green
so I go off and I work with Danny and
um you know God Rest his soul Danny's
passed away but he became a great mentor
to me and he was super old school
because back in the day editors loved to
go have lunch in a place where they had
a bar
right yep
and so I
the soup to go
right
Niche let's go have a lunch at a shishi
place that's what he would call it and
so we'd go to Musso and Frank's we'd go
oh my God we'd go all over Hollywood and
but I noticed that when we'd come back
he'd sort of sit down at the couch and
then he'd have the trades and then next
thing you know he was asleep
so this happened like
like the whole week and before the end
of the week like the like Wednesday or
something like that I go great so what
am I gonna do read the script again
so finally
one day I knew he was just about ready
to doze off I go listen I go hey Danny
would you mind if I work on on a scene
um and he goes knock yourself out
darling and off off he'd go and so uh so
I'd work on the scene
and and the only reason I asked him that
was because we were working in tandem so
he'd be working on the bigger machine I
work on the smaller machine and he'd go
okay at this point I need a close-up on
this actor okay off I go I look cut it
hand it to him he you know splice it in
this would go on he never said to me
goes why'd you pick that he just put it
in and then we'd play it so I kind of
knew that we had we were in sync
so I finally said to him I go okay Hey
listen Danny well you know you're you're
relaxing uh would you mind if I work on
a scene and he goes oh knock yourself
out Marlin
relaxing relaxing anyways so I'd work on
a scene at about five o'clock I'd go tap
tap tap hey Danny
um before we go home would you mind
looking at what I did today and you go
and get up and he'd look at the scene
and he he looked at it and he takes
something out
and then
slice it together or rearrange something
and then it goes there I go oh great
thank you so then the next day I do the
same thing
and you look at the scene and he goes
what's wrong with it I go uh I don't
know but it feels good and he goes yeah
it's great
so that be that was our
that was my mentorship that I actually
had a teacher there and not one time did
he look at me like well that's a stupid
God or what are you thinking about and
so he became you know very helpful in my
transition so yeah
because he's giving you license to edit
you didn't have to get the job to do the
editing you were there and he was
mentoring you on the you know in the
moment right on site there and and it
wasn't a question about you know someone
having to believe in you when you didn't
have an editing credit I I have one more
uh question do you have any
um any advice for students uh student
film editors
well I think the important thing is you
know if you're going to a school
um and there's a film program
volunteered to cut the the master thesis
for the students you know any kind of
Hands-On
um will help you in the future
um and you know don't be afraid to tell
people what your goal is you know what
what you want to do because there are a
lot of people as you can tell there are
a lot of people that are willing to help
you if you stay enthusiastic you keep
out of your people's way and the main
thing is to listen and to observe
because by listening and observing the
way Robert Altman worked I was able to
formulate my own style of editing
and I think that there's so many
opportunities now uh for people to do
what we do
um and and if you can't go to a school
just look in the want ads
because I'm sure that in the want ads
they're you know Industrials you know uh
uh films are really in demand too
because you know that Microsoft uh and
my son who is an editor he did a lot of
promos for Microsoft now you never would
think that Microsoft or Google or Yahoo
would have that kind of department or
any major
um like Procter and Gamble I mean those
those places I think and even in the I
don't want to suggest anybody join the
Army but but but but those those areas
have film editing because they want to
do recruiting films and I know that some
of the older editors that's how they got
their start was editing recruiting films
for second world war and
um so but but I think you just need to
keep your goal in mind and don't let
anybody
discourage you because I think that part
of it is that's the they're just jealous
that they don't have the guts to do what
you want to do and
um and that you know happened like in a
reunion where uh High School reunion
where one of the most popular boys when
I was going to school came up to me and
said to me goes you know I I'm really
jealous of you and I go why and he goes
because you went and did what you wanted
to do and if I
a woman that grew up in Vancouver's
Chinatown can do what I'm doing now than
anybody can do it and I would say just
always be open uh always be learning
continue to meet people who are
following the path that you want to meet
and and and like you said go for it
and I think Jody part of it too is
networking you know if you go to school
and you meet
a couple people you really are in sync
with well then they all know two more
people and those people would know four
more people and so I always suggest that
you know to new members um in the
editor's guild uh when they ask you know
how do we how do I become an editor well
that's what you do is you find all these
people that's why people that go to
universities do so well like Barry
Jenkins and joy McMillian who used to be
my assistant they all went to Florida
State so there is a group of support so
if anybody needs a job they know
somebody that will turn you on to a job
and absolutely
yeah just keep that you know keep your
eye on the prize that's what I said I'm
impressed well Maisie thank you so much
for generously sharing your insights and
inspiration through your Rich stories
your diverse experiences your deep
wisdom and it's really been great to get
to know you actually better and I
applaud that you're opening up the world
of film editing to so many people and
especially to our students in Kenya
thank you so much thank you for
participating in the Academy's visiting
artist film series film Aid Edition for
film editing